-Our next guest is a talented
actor who you know
from his work as the
new Fresh Prince
on Peacock's most-streamed
original series, "Bel-Air."
All ten episodes are
streaming now on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-There is a house
full of people in Bel-Air
that want you around, man.
All you gotta do
is get in your car and go back.
I promise, everything
will work itself out.
-No.
It's done.
It's over.
You told me that this city
would try to make me forget
who I am and where I come from.
And you were right.
-Please welcome to the show,
Jabari Banks, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show!
How are you?
-Oh, I'm great. Great.
Excited to be here.
Thank you for having me.
-I'm so happy to have you.
Congratulations on this show.
For those who haven't seen it,
they might recognize
from the clip, this is more
a reimagining than a remake.
This is a dramatic retelling
of the "Fresh Prince" story.
When you first heard
that they were doing that,
what was your first reaction.
-I was like, "No. No. No way."
And then I actually
saw the trailer
that Morgan Cooper
posted on YouTube,
and I watched it and I was like,
"Okay, I can get with this."
-Yeah.
-And I couldn't imagine
that two years later,
I'd be, you know, in this seat.
-Now, I do have to point out
that you were not alive
when this show was on TV.
-No, no.
-But what was your level of
familiarity with "Fresh Prince"?
-I am a "Fresh Prince
of Bel-Air" fanatic.
My family had
the six-season box set.
We have Will Smith
Christmas sweaters.
We love the show.
-Okay, so you did know
the show, then.
-Yes. Oh, for sure. For sure.
-And this is very interesting --
in real life, true story,
you have an Uncle Phil.
-I do. His name is James Brogan.
-Okay, now, neither
of those names are Phil.
-Right. No, no, no.
But he lives in Philly.
I lived with him in Philly,
so we called him Uncle Phil.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-Yeah.
-Are a lot of Uncle Phils
different people's names,
but they're from Philadelphia?
-Yeah, not really. Not really.
-Okay.
-He's the only one.
He's special to us.
-I mean, it does
seem like those
are a lot of like sort of maybe,
you know,
harbingers that you would be
in a "Fresh Prince" one day,
that you had an Uncle Phil
who wasn't
even a real Uncle Phil.
-I know, right?
It's kind of strange, yeah.
-And then it was your dad,
your dad was the one
who thought this
would be a good part for you.
-Yes. He sent me an article.
He was like,
"They're casting for Bel-Air.
You should do this.
Check it out.
Call someone and figure it out."
And I was like,
"Okay, I'll try."
And then actually
a couple of months later,
my people actually
gave me the call.
-'Cause your dad's
not in show business.
He just reads articles
and sends you ideas?
-Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Yeah. Yeah.
He's super supportive
and I love that.
-I'm lucky enough to have
one of those as well.
But now that
you've got the part,
do you think he walks around
telling everybody,
"You know this was my idea."
-Yeah.
I'm sure he does.
He's actually in the audience
right now.
-Oh, well, that's great!
Well, let me tell you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Shout out to my dad.
Yeah.
-You go take all that credit.
-Exactly.
-You take all that credit.
-Yeah.
-That would be -- my dad
would take the credit,
if he pointed it out.
So you auditioned for it,
and you know, I think this was
one of those parts
where you cast a wide net.
You're trying to find, you know,
lightning in a bottle,
and tell us how you found out
you got the part.
-So Will actually called me
on FaceTime.
I actually got onto
the call thinking
that it was an audition, right?
So Morgan Cooper was like,
"We want to do one more
creative session with you."
And I was like,
"What does that mean?"
So I had all my sides lined up.
I was like, "I'm gonna give
them everything that I have."
And I got on the call
and Will surprised me.
And that was the moment
that changed my life.
-Had you met him
through the process?
-No, no.
-Oh, so the first time
you saw Will Smith
was him telling you that you
were going to be him in this.
That's pretty cool.
-Yeah, it was very surreal.
-That is a very cool thing.
-Yeah.
My life literally got flipped,
turned upside down.
-Yeah, it did get flipped,
And then how did you celebrate?
Is that news that you can
even celebrate or is it too big?
-Oh, no, I just went to sleep.
-You went to sleep?
-Yeah, I just went
straight to sleep.
Yeah. It was too much emotion
in my body. It was a lot.
-I'm impressed that you
could go to sleep,
but that speaks well to your
ability to have an even keel.
-Oh, I can sleep anywhere.
I could sleep right here
if I wanted to.
-I'm like that, too.
Very good at that.
Now you have -- you're
the youngest of five boys.
-Yes.
-How do they feel
about your success?
Are they as supportive as...
-Oh, they're so jealous.
-Yeah? Good.
-No, I'm joking.
No, no, they're very supportive
and they love the show.
And we have a group chat
and they talk about it
all the time and they're like,
"No spoilers, no spoilers."
And I just love seeing
all the messages, yeah.
-Did you guys, were you
as you grew up,
were you the kind of kids
who always got along,
or did you wail on each other?
-Oh, no.
Oh, a lot of fights during
the summer, but healthy fights.
-And you're low man
on the totem pole,
so did you take it
pretty bad in back in the day?
-Yeah, I got it bad.
I got it real bad.
-Alright, Good.
-Yeah, but that, you know,
that gave me the strength
to carry on, you know?
-Yeah. I'm glad.
I'm glad you rose above it.
You got nominated
for a BET Award for Best Actor.
Congratulations.
That's a very cool thing.
[ Applause ]
-Thanks.
Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah. Yeah.
Super excited about that.
Yeah.
-And you're gonna start shooting
a second season in September,
which is also great news.
-Yeah, Season 2 on the way.
[ Applause ]
-We were talking backstage,
'cause I would say, you know,
you got some time,
and you were telling me
you're going to work on music.
So that's still
a passion for you?
-Yes, music was actually
my first passion.
And a lot of people ask me,
they're like,
"Do you love music more
or acting more?"
And I was like, it's like
choosing between your children.
But yeah,
music was my first love,
and I'm returning to it soon.
-So when you went to school,
you went to, like,
an art school?
-An art school in Philadelphia.
University of the Arts.
And I studied musical theater,
so music and acting
all at the same time,
yeah, and I loved it.
-When did you fall in love
with musical theater?
Was that something you found
in high school?
-Yeah, something I found
in high school.
The first show
I did was "The Wiz,"
where I really
fell in love with it.
-Who were you in "The Wiz"?
-I was the lion.
-The lion?
-I wanted to be the scarecrow,
but they didn't have
too many guys, you know,
so they put me as a lion.
-And when you find out
you got the lion,
did they have an actual lion
FaceTime you and tell you?
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
It's dope, because my mom
actually made the costume.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-My parents are very supportive.
-That's fantastic.
-She's in the audience too.
[ Applause ]
-Here we go!
-Yeah, yeah.
-I was a Wilbur in a production
of "Charlotte's Web."
-No way.
-This is a true story.
You know, congratulations
on all your success
and further acting work.
But my mom said we read --
she goes,
"I found your old Wilbur
costume that we made."
And I was like, "Oh, I don't
really remember it."
And it was just a t-shirt,
and then there were, like,
iron-on letters
that spelled out "SOME PIG."
-Yeah, right, right.
-And I was like...
I've got a feeling your mom
did a better job
with your lion costume.
-Yeah. No, she did.
-And so is this something,
did your parents,
did your older siblings,
did they all know
from a young age
that this was the path
you were going to go on,
that you were gonna follow this?
-Well, we all played sports
growing up,
so we thought in some
form or fashion
that we were going to be
in the league of...some league.
No, they had no clue.
-Gotcha.
So you were good
at sports, too?
'Cause a lot of
my coaches were like,
"You should do comedy."
-No, I was
pretty good at sports.
-What was your sport?
What was your big one?
-Basketball and football.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Basketball. Loved basketball.
I thought I was going
to go to the NBA.
-But it does seem like
they're really supportive,
so when you tell everybody,
"Hey, I'm gonna go to this
performing arts college,"
was everybody, like,
over the moon?
-Yeah, for sure. Yeah.
That was the only college
I got into.
-Okay. [ Laughing ]
-But my parents, they made sure
I went to school.
-That's great.
What were your other jobs,
before you get a job
as big as
being the Fresh Prince?
-I had a lot of different jobs,
actually.
I worked at Six Flags
as Bugs Bunny.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Hopefully, they made
the costume in that case.
-They did, yeah. For sure.
I only worked there
for one day, though.
-One day? What happened?
-The eye holes were, like,
this big.
-Oh, you gave up the job.
-I gave up. Oh, yeah, for sure.
It was in April. Yeah.
So it wasn't even
the summer yet.
-Yeah.
-It was going to get hotter.
-It was a hot day at Six Flags?
-I was like, no way.
But actually, before I got
the "Bel-Air" gig,
I was working
in a manufacturing factory
in Temecula, California.
-What were you doing
at the Temecula factory?
-I was wrapping gutters.
-Wrapping gutters?
So when you got,
when Will Smith called,
was it
a situation where you said,
"Let me think about it?"
-Oh, no way.
No, no, no. Not at all.
No, I had actually gotten fired
from that job.
I was working there for a month.
I don't do well with,
you know...[ Laughing ]
And so this is a situation
where, do you think
the person who fired you
from the gutter wrapping job
is aware
of what's happened since?
-Oh, I hope they are.
I hope they are.
I hope you're watching this.
[ Applause ]
-The Bugs Bunny thing
is really interesting to me,
because I didn't think the small
eye holes would be something --
You feel like they would have
solved that problem.
-It's awful. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-They have a small, little fan
in there,
and they think that
that would suffice, but no.
-Like a little electric fan?
-A little electric fan, yeah.
-Okay, near your ear?
Is it like...?
-It's like, somewhere up there.
I don't remember where.
-And it doesn't
get the job done?
-No, not at all.
-Yeah.
-And I spent my whole paycheck
on the food there.
-Okay.
-Yeah, this is really not...
I feel bad that they're
our main sponsor tonight.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, God.
Shout out to Six Flags.
-Sure, shout out to Six Flags.
I mean, obviously.
I mean, I think a lot
of this was Jabari's fault.
-Yeah. Oh, for sure.
-Hey, man congratulations
so much on the show.
It's really such a cool thing.
I think, like,
everyone, there was this,
"What are they going
to do with it?"
And it's so cool
how they nailed the landing,
and it's really amazing
that they found you.
You're so great at it.
Thanks for being here,
my friend.
-Thank you, man.
-Really appreciate it.
Jabari Banks, everybody!
The entire first season
of "Bel-Air"
is streaming now on Peacock.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."